you're considered by many to be one of
the greatest if not the greatest chess
players of all time but you're also one
of the best fantasy football aka soccer
competitors in the world plus recently
picking up poker and uh competing at a
world-class level so before chess let's
talk football and greatness
uh you're a real madrid fan
so let me ask you the ridiculous big
question who do you think is the
greatest football
aka soccer player of all time can you
make the case for messi can you make the
case for cristiano ronaldo
pele maradona does somebody anybody jump
to mind
i think it's pretty hard to make a case
for
anybody else
than messi for his uh for his all-around
game
and uh
frankly like my
real madrid fandom sort of
uh predates the ronaldo
era era uh this the second ronaldo not
not not the first one so i always liked
ronaldo but i always kind of thought
that
messi was uh
was uh better uh and um i went to quite
a number of madrid games and they've
always been super helpful to me down
there the only thing is that
like they asked me they were going to do
an interview and they were going to ask
me who my favorite player was and
um
i said somebody else i think i said isko
at that point and i was like okay take
two now you say ronaldo
so for them it was um
it was very important but it wasn't
wasn't that huge to um
uh